j'accueille bernard laporte
[Musique]
c'était au soir du deuxième tour juste
après l'élection de nicolas sarkozy
les liens entre les deux hommes ne sont
plus un secret pour personne depuis la
campagne électorale bernard laporte fait
partie de la garde rapprochée de nicolas
sarkozy il était de tous les meetings
depuis la rencontre d'arcachon en 2004
il solide amitié s'est installée entre
eux quand j'étais dans la voiture c'est
champs-elysées à midi que j'entraîne
dieu claude guillaneau c'est mon nom
mais beaucoup d'émotion messieurs je
crois que c'est la moins des choses
parce que bon c'est pour moi une grande
fierté la porte est nommé secrétaire
d'état à la jeunesse et aux sports par
anticipation c'est une première dans
l'histoire de la vème république
il entrera en fonctions qu'après la
coupe du monde
mais d'ici là il a promis qu'il se
concentrerait sur la préparation du
quinze de france
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
bernard laporte dans son appartement de
boulogne billancourt en région
parisienne
l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux sports a
une vue imprenable sur les stades
parisien
bernard est un lève tôt son plaisir du
matin boire son café devant les chaînes
info au quotidien ça coince à 7h10 heure
c
c'est
les fosses on voit ce qui se passe qui
s'est passé fait au courant de
l'actualité
j'habite à paris depuis 1995 je suis mon
but est de me trouver c'est bordelaise
une région que j'adore bordeaux le
bassin d'arcachon c'est un endroit
merveilleux et dont je suis monté à
paris parce que j'étais venue pour
entraîner le ca français et voyez que
j'étais pas loin puisque le stade et il
est en face alors là il est en pleine
reconstruction puisqu'il a été démolie à
leur constat tout neuf
le stade jean bouin terrain de jeu
officiel du stade français est
actuellement en pleine rénovation je
regardais la démolition de les bulles
les tribunaux disait pour nous et c'est
je me disais c'est un petit peu de moi
qui semblant puisque j'ai opéré pendant
sur le banc de touche dans un stade jean
bouin mais l'ancien entraîneur du quinze
de france à d'autres passions moi je
suis un amoureux de la chanson française
ça c'est clair vous le voyez quoi de
françois
miga chanson française dalida j'adore ça
le café avalé bernard laporte s'équipent
pour affronter les rendez vous de la
journée on va au bureau de fans de sport
trouille comme très sportif il faut y
aller à pied non moins grand
moi j'aime paris parce que j'aime le
monde et que moi j'aime quand ça fait ça
brasse aller à bordeaux sur le bassin
d'arcachon c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
convivialité
avant le bureau il fait une pause au
resto de son vieil ami antoine le rituel
c'est de commenter les matches de la
veille
ils ont perdu 24 à verre
speechi el-aurassi a perdu deux points
et demi à g
[Musique]
et ses portes à la france elle a pu
réduire curieux
l'ancien rugbyman businessman avérés se
dirige enfin vers les locaux de femmes
de sport un site communautaire ici le
roi c'est maradona ltd
je vais croiser à marseille un homme
hors du commun avec une histoire
fabuleuse
qui ces nouvelles vidéos de sport au
fond du couloir un petit studio c'est
ici qu'il enregistre sa chronique
bonjour le sport aujourd'hui on va
parler de la 12e journée du top 14 avec
bernard bonjour madame bonjour j bernard
laporte a créé ce site internet avec
denis charvet yannick noah et basile
boli leur job faire des pronostics et d
analyse sportive d'accord c'est bien
beau de parler de jeu d'attaqué etc mais
si tu ne parle que de jeu et qui
finalement tu prêt que des essais
meeddat a plus d'équipé un jeune
géographe des sports nouvelle qu'a fait
de parler de l'équipe on était content
pas content de la sélection par sa
sélection et c est ça on a recréé sur
sur sur le site fait en sorte que ce
soit vraiment participatif un lieu
d'échangé de convivialité et de partage
voilà c'était sale après il ya la
dimension que j'appelle moi
professionnels et salir en parle c'est
yvonne de l'actualité professionnelle
mois du rugby basile boli du football
denis fait des vidéos seraient pour
alimenter le site et notre merveilleuse
dream team de jeunes et qui est là mais
tout ça en synergie mais tout ça en
place et voilà donc on est on est on est
fier de ce de cela ce qui vraiment sont
au four et au moulin eliseo mathieu
guillaume alex et train de nous
rejoindre et stan et l'on reconnaît
l'esprit d'équipé chez rubis d'où sa
mesure n'existe pas et lausanne nous
n'existe pas et comme c'est ça il n'y a
pas plus forts l'un de l'autre et c'est
une équipe que chacun a sa partition à
jouer
avec une quinzaine de sociétés à gérer
bernard laporte passe désormais ses
journées au téléphone
sa vie d'entraîneur c'est pour lui de
l'histoire ancienne on avait proposé le
sabre dames trenet et qui veulent une
équipe de rugby avec pour but
d'entraîner de repartir avec une équipe
de rugby je les ai déjà fait j'ai plus
envie d'aller au quotidien et entraîner
les joueurs j'avais plus la passion j'ai
un métier merveilleux mais que j'ai fait
pratiquement une 15 ans entre l'équipe
de france pour le club et l'équipe de
france est aujourd'hui j'ai envie
d'autre chose parce que quand il alors
éviter que dans le rugby quoi et donc
moi j'ai beau j'ai besoin de beaucoup de
choses bernard laporte parviendra-t-il à
mener toutes ses affaires comme il a
entraîné les bleus
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
bernard laporte bernard bonsoir jean
bienvenu dans tout le monde en a parlé
alors vous êtes né le 1er juillet 1964 à
rodez dans l'aveyron votre père était
agent edf il passait sa vie est ce
qu'elle allait les poteaux électriques
oui au départ et après il a relevé des
compteurs puisque les problèmes de dos
votre mère debout à 5 heures du matin
pour livrer la dépêche du midi avant
d'entamer une journée de femme de ménage
tafer vous dites on appartenait à la
classe ouvrière oui je suis très fier
ouais parce que j'ai vécu des choses de
merveilleuses on partage plus qu'on a
mais on est content de tout on révise
assez facilement alors pas étonnant
qu'en 81 vous collier des affiches pour
françois mitterrand il ya des photos de
françois mitterrand au mur chez vous
vous allez au meeting maintient une
vraie passion dans la famille pour
mitterrand oui tout à fait mon père
était engagé ma mère - mais quand même
sur lui de faire de vrais de son mari
mais on va pas engager avec la carte du
parti socialiste est effectivement quand
on nage avait 17 ans - 81eme donc bien
encaissé cour a réaffiché c'est sortir
et boire des coups après un mauvais coup
avec des pauses et puis surtout faire
partie de quelque chose qu'on aura fini
de faire cette appartenance et bien un
moment j'étais le mouvement pour
françois mitterrand et puis je rappelle
toujours le 10 mai 81 ans est faite
cette vraie intrigue merveilleux un
grand souvenir des gens heureux dans une
petite salle des fêtes de village quoi
alors autre passion le ballon vous
découvrez le rugby en c1 1 à l'âge de 9
ans en accompagnant en voisin à
l'entraînement et quand vous voyez le
match de rugby vous dites c'est ce que
je veux j'ai vu du tout quoi j'ai mis
des prix j'ai vu des plus grands j'ai vu
des plus costauds rouge j'ai vu tout et
puis je me suis dit mais moi j'étais
tout petit toute une région comme la
nôtre japon je me suis dit j'ai gagné ma
place là j'ai un truc à faire et puis je
sentais dessus dans ce sport l'envi fait
l'obligation
d'aller vers les autres c'est cet esprit
d'équipé fort en rugby j'ai tout de
suite senti j'ai de suite voulu
appartenir à ce bras ce monde là donc
c'est pour ça que le samedi d'après j'ai
été mon premier entraînement
malheureusement votre carrière de
rugbyman va s'interrompre brutalement à
21 ans au volant de votre samba après un
assoupissement vous encastré dans un
platane à 120 kilomètres à l'heure si la
libération de l'armée c'est le jourdain
sur deux là qui comme on dit et donc
j'allais rejoindre et pottas moi de mon
équipe de rugby de gaillac chacun a fait
son service militaire dans une france on
devait se re se rejoindre à gaillac et
puis voilà je me suis assoupi faisait
c'était le 25 juillet effectivement il
faisait très chaud quand je me suis
réveillé dans cet hôpital militaire puis
c'est un corps dépendant de l'armée mais
j'ai vite compris que d'abord que
c'était grave et là j'ai compris que
peut-être le sport pour moi était fin et
j'ai envie de dire je vivais pour le
rugby c'était ma passion ouais c'était
mon moteur est donc un véritable coup
d'arrêt et puis on fume au fil du temps
j'ai compris que peut-être je ne
rejouerai jamais donc j'ai dit à ma mère
va m'acheter les livres sur
l'entraînement parce que je me suis dit
faut surtout pas que je que je
déconnecte ce milieu qui mêle 20 et donc
je vais entraîner qu'extraordinaire si
vous arrivera à convaincre un colonel
ex-dirigeant de rugby de vous
accompagner à l'entraînement de bègles
c'est votre seule sortie de la semaine
et là vous êtes couchée au fond de la
voiture et vous observez les les
combinaisons vous notez tout cas vous
apprenez votre boulot d'entraîneur en
fait j'ai eu la chance vêtements que
dans cet hôpital militaire le des
colonels responsable médecin personnel
était aussi un dirigeant de bègles et ce
qui m'a facilité les choses parce qu'il
me parlait de rugby m'a mené aux
entraînements effectivement et donc de
ce côté là j'étais privilégiez donc en
86 vous retourner sur le terrain
vous reprenez votre licence à gaillac en
87 c'est bègles dont vous devenez
capitaine en 1991 ensuite c'est bordeaux
en 93 et en 95 paris vous avez été
recruté par max guazini pour devenir
l'entraîneur du stade français et ça va
être un succès fou on a vécu avec max et
tous les joueurs français une
installation formidable donc des
souvenirs et une expérience géniale
ouais à votre ligne de miel durera
jusqu'en 1999 avec comme point d'orgue
le championnat de france en 1998 car en
1999 le président de la fédération
française de rugby vous propose de
prendre la tête de l'équipe de france de
rugby et vous devenez sélectionneur du
quinze de france pas mal et je rappelle
très bien le jour il m'a téléphoné il
m'a dit voilà je vous vois je veux te
voir demain j'ai vite compris je vais
jamais dans les journaux tout le monde
disait éventuellement la porte qui va
entraîner je me suis dit si je convoque
c'est pas pour rien en 2002
l'international rugby board vous elie
entraîneur mondiale de l'année oui me
sauve src oui donc beaucoup de fierté
mais c'est surtout dû aux résultats des
joueurs sur le terrain - saint-etienne
c'est parce que tout simplement on avait
fait une très très grosse saison 1 et
2002 que les joueurs avaient été hyper
performant sur le terrain et c'est moi
qui ai tiré la quintessence mais voilà
alors parallèlement à votre carrière
sportive après un bac professionnel en
électronique vous travaillez d'abord à
l'edf comme papa ensuite france télécom
ensuite vous rentrez dans le business
alors vous occupez de bars de
restaurants de camping de vignolles
d'immobilier de casino évidemment ce
n'est pas illégal mais ça fait un peu
jaser alors vous dites banon tout est
clean j'ai pas prostituée je vends pas
de gamme quoi je vois pas pourquoi on
emmerde avec ça mais minutieux mais je
trouve tellement il faudrait plutôt
pousser les gens à faire ça le voit
aujourd'hui avec ces jeunes de se dire
non on a peur de l'avenir et érable et
lancez-vous
moi je commence j'ai fait moi j'ai
commencé par hypothéquait ce que j'avais
à dire pas grand chose et puis
effectivement moi j'ai commencé on l'a
pris en gérance demeure avec quatre
potes du rugby ouais je vais rien à vous
reprocher
si j'avais des choses à me reprocher je
serais pas là alors justement tout ça
n'empêche pas nicolas sarkozy de vous
nommer secrétaire d'état chargée des
sports lors de son élection et ensuite
en 2008 auprès d'annie mans il ajoute la
jeunesse et la vie associative
ouais là aussi l'usure de
merveilleux c'est à dire que le
président qui m'avait dit en avant à
l'époque il était encore ministre
intérieur des coûts de gilles gagner
j'aimerais que tu sois mon midi sports
bon je sais pas si c'était vrai ou pas
peu importe et il a tenu parole et pour
moi là aussi ça a été comme comme quand
on est en équipe de france c'est quelque
chose
auquel tu ne t'attends pas ouais et puis
voilà ça t'arrive et c'est merveilleux
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre mot
sarkozy devenu un ami à vous en plus
ouais c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup je conduis avant pas vous
l'avez connu d'arcachon contrepartie de
foot qu'on diable et avec lui arrachant
je les connais en 2004 est fait par cash
on voit là il c'est quelqu'un que
j'admire profondément j'aime ce genre de
mec avancée qui voilà qui
qui pue ce qui pousse les murs qu'on est
ce que parce que notamment ils faut les
pousser quelles ont été les réactions de
votre entourage vos parents par exemple
ouais c'était par compliqué mais bon dit
à mon père socialiste depuis tous les
temps mais papa je vais certainement
rentrer au gouvernement d'écossé
quantité mais mon père il a pleuré au
téléphone avec m voilà et j'ai dit mais
tu sais si tu veux pas qu'ils aillent je
ne dirais pas vous mais je savais très
bien quelle serait sa réaction oui pour
un père s'est fait cesser ses fils
ministre c'est merveilleux qu'on a et
voilà lorsque vous avez fait c'est qu'à
l'époque vous étiez ministre vous ne
verriez plus vos affaires c'est la bnp
qui gérait 1 exactement peut pas ouais
mais ce qui est tout à fait normal c'est
à dire qu on occulte vos mandats mais
quelque part c'est ça aussi c'est une
hypocrisie si vous êtes plus pdg de
votre société donc d'accord ma femme
comme pour l'aider que les associés
avaient ils vous appellent à dire qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire si on veut faire ça
ce que ce qui est sûr c'est que pendant
cette période-là je n'ai voulu avoir
aucune interaction avec quoi que ce soit
ça c'est évident ça n'est jamais demandé
de permis de construire est jamais
demandé une augmentation de quoi que ce
soit c'est évident que j'ai dit pendant
le temps où je serai là statu quo ont
retenu comme on est quel a été le
meilleur moment de cette période de
ministre la période pékin les jeux
olympiques un l'abandonner les jeux
olympiques et les jeux paralympiques
ça c'est vraiment des souvenirs parce
que d'abord je connaissais pas bon le
rugby n'était pas un sport olympique
donc j'ai vraiment découvert cet univers
ce monde là et c'était ça c'était
magnifique merveilleux et le pire moment
le pire moment c'est
c'est quand tu dois partir quand même
hein c'est évident parce que j'avais
aucune amertume donc mais quand vous
partez vous partez quand même assez
c'est sympa avec ministère faisait
justement oui tout a bien commencé il ya
eu quand même pas mal de dents merde
quoi pas mal de gars il ya un jour où
vous déclarer mon nouveau métier s'il me
plaît j'y resterai s'il me plaît pas je
ne ferai plus mon histoire elle est peu
curieuse que j'ai été nommé en juin avec
prise de fonction en octobre puisqu'au
milieu y avait la coupe du monde bien
sûr et donc pendant la coupe du monde de
rugby ce moment et me posais me poser
que des questions sur halo gouvernement
avait tablé ici on est du monde de rugby
1 mais je suis pas encore au
gouvernement un éboulement dans la gare
se manger d'écouté j'y vais avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé si ça me
décourage arrêtés auraient tout
simplement roselyne bachelot a été
convié aux machos elle a dit oui on a
pas à dire ça mais non je ne regrette
pas de l'avoir dit et et de j ai pris du
plaisir mais si je n'avais pas pris
j'aurais arrêté vraiment pourquoi je
vous serai service pour être ministre
alors un jour vous présentez vos voeux à
la presse et vous dites pour le budget
des sports on n'atteint pas les 3% mais
c'étaient des promesse électorale de
nicolas sarkozy
alors voilà je n'ai jamais dit ça avant
le très bien il ya eu plein de rumeurs
puisque je reprends ce monde-là hyper
médiatique je dirais c'est que par
moments on sort les phrases d'un
contexte où vous fait dire des choses
que vous n'avez pas dit oui ça j'ai
trouvé ça très très curieux ça m'est
arrivé là l'occase mais j'ai vu que
j'arrivais à peine 2 bis était obligé à
prédire derniers mois j'ai jamais dit ça
ya un voyage aux antilles c'est pas
grave mais quand vous dites les antilles
jamais venu je voulais les voir de vive
voix quoi ouais mais ça je voudrais je
voudrais comme le montre que j'ai dit ça
y'est je me rappelle pas du tout mais
c'est possible que ce que j'ai fait ce
lapsus mais là aussi je me rappelle pas
du coup et pierre aliker 401 en vous
dites suis là et je vois pas le prochain
tournoi des six nations c'est les
avaient que c'est les antilles et et qui
a dit ça vous jamais ah bon mais moi
j'ai jamais dit ça à la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jo de pékin vous je
voudrais que tous les médias boycott à
cause du côté dictatoriale du régime
chinois vous l'avez 10 non j'ai pas dit
ça c'est à dire qu'est ce qui s'est
passé j'ai fait une émission où les gens
s'attaquent indigents oui il faut pas y
aller un c'est les droits de l'homme
c'est lamentable on ne devrait boycotter
j'ai dit mais les premiers qui doivent
boycotter ces vous d'accord or ce que je
sais c'est que vous y serez devant moi à
becker et ça a été le cas bon après bon
l'histoire de la fille de rachida dati
vous dites que je tiens à dire que c'est
pas moi le père de l'enfant de rachida
dati là aussi on est dans un monde de
médias qui perd médiatique je me suis
rendu compte de l'ampleur de leurs
humeurs et j'ai un pote qui m'appelle de
new york un dj il ya eu deux lignes
disant vraiment pensé que j'étais j'ai
des tas d faut stopper puis n'est plus
pour votre femme surtout ma femme et ma
fille parce que hein une femme pour
effectivement vous pouvez vite su
expliquer que non ma fille
voilà face à face et qui dit mais qu'est
ce qu'on me dit à la faculté qu'est ce
qu'ils voient comme un génie il forum
tout un vigile et 10 encore une fois ça
me chercher je lui ai dit avant que j'ai
réalisé donc ce n'était pas faux pas
pour laquelle et puis la dernière chose
c'est quand la marseillaise est sifflée
vous dites il aura plus jamais de match
contre l'algérie le maroc ou la tunisie
au stade de france il faut jouer en
province et qu'est ce qu'on a dit il ne
faut plus jouer quand au sénat sur leurs
points même pas de france jamet 10 avr
est ce que finalement
vous n'avez pas été projeté dans un
monde qui n'était pas le vôtre parce que
vous êtes tout d'une pièce vous êtes un
sportif vous êtes un ace que d'un seul
coup dans ce monde un peu tordu de la
politique vous étiez peut-être pas les
classes dire que c'était pas mon monde
c'est sûr mais dire que ça d'abord on
s'y habitue c'est pas compliqué mais
mais ce qui est navrant c'est qu'ils
étaient 24 les sportifs on a envie de
suite de tordre le cou à la rumeur dit
non mais moi j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas
fait s'il est au bout d'un moment il
faut faire comment il faut pour laisser
dire il faut travailler puis voilà on
passe à une information chasse l'autre
d'histoire que j'avais souffert de ce
monde politique comme maintenant et
quand kouchner vous calcule pas par
exemple mais je n'avais pas souffert
j'ai des choses qui m'ont déplu sahin
effectivement mais j'ai raté pas le son
ambiant bernard kouchner a pas dit
bonjour [ __ ] mais mais mais par contre
c'est vrai que ça me surprenez le monde
politique est un monde individuel c'est
tout - ça c'est la vie la véritable
différence avec le monde du sport c'est
chacun pour soi ça c'est évident mais
après j'ai vu des mecs merveilleux dans
le monde politique alors le 23 juin 2009
nicolas sarkozy vous remplace par rama
yade on est mal vécue mais comme je
disais pas d'amertume mais quand tu sors
de la cenco qu'aucun ministre donc c'est
vrai que puis surtout tu as plus c'est
fini ce jour là demain tu vois plus tes
conseillers de ses habitudes et c est
moi j'ai rien contre moi j'avais le
privilège je dirais d'avoir des
activités qui m'attendait oui mais je
m'imagine celui qui n'a rien quoi sinon
ça doit pas être facile hein oui pas
d'amertume mais par contre oui tu as
quelque chose au fond demi de coin est
ce que vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque
vous étiez ministre
non mais par contre
j'ai accepté et j'ai perdu beaucoup
d'argent que j'ai accepté parce que
j'avais des contrats qui duré deux ans
après la coupe du monde et j'ai dit pas
comment faire ça pas de prix - donc je
regrette absolument rien vous êtes
rancunier contre certaines personnes
vous avez croisé dans le monde politique
à l'époque non alors moi je fais partie
des gens qui sont pas inclus ni moins
qu'un j'aime pas et j'aime pas je parle
pas 1 voilà donc si ici si je parle pas
ça fait aussi leur téléphone parce que
je les aime pas vain mais par contre je
passe ma vie à dépenser mon énergie
quand on perd quand on est contente elle
parce que la vie est tellement courte
que j'ai envie de dépenser pour faire
des choses positives et pas pour
m'occuper des cons voilà bernard si
c'était à refaire tout ça qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez papa est
plein de trucs que j'aurais pas pareil a
pas une en particulier que je que je ne
referai pas pareil
avec recul quand j'étais un vrai qu'il
le fera dit des choses que je ferais que
je referai différemment au ministère
c'est paraît il n'y a pas eu les
spéciales le jour j'allais mourir comme
tout le monde comme tout le monde qu'est
ce que vous voudriez qu'on marque comme
épitaphe sur votre tombe bernard et je
sais pas s'il ya quelque chose ouais moi
j'aime les gens généreux moi j'aime les
gens qui donnent un je viens d'un milieu
modeste où on appris à donner on a on se
satisfait de ce que l'ona et on me donne
est donc j'aimerais way bernard généreux
je sais pas il ya plein de monde mais
généreux simple et puis surtout je
voudrais qui est bien sûr beaucoup de
monde
et que les mecs à prix fort c'est une
belle fête et qui se disent b c'est un
bon mec
c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vous merci bernard mercier
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu